you
I've taught some cases on culture so
that gives me a little bit of
credibility I hope on that that's core
but on the venture piece actually last
year I took a leave to run a small
startup in the fitness industry so
hopefully now I have more credibility on
the the entrepreneurial angle so one of
things I want to do is to just give our
panelists a chance to get a sense for
who you are so let me kind of ask you
how many of you are either first or
second year MBAs okay and alumni
all right some alumni and those of you
who are alumni how many are kind of on
the entrepreneurial side doing ventures
all right and any investors and ventures
they don't want to put up their hands
probably okay great so on our panel we
have Andrew Amy Hossein and Scott and
I'll let them kind of introduce
themselves and say a little bit about
their organization their cultures you
see see that's just cuz they've never
let me teach the Sloan's so Sloan's once
flown any other Sloan's okay um no no
hang on I should remember this any PhD
students any doctoral students well they
are locked away in their cubby holes
studying and writing papers which is
which is good thank you for reminding me
of that the other bit of housekeeping
that I should do is to ask you to turn
off your PDAs and cell phones
we're taping and I think we've got
wireless mics and like a jumbo airliner
any static could could bring down the
flame or it could bring the wrath of a
Nancy on you so so please turn those off
all right so the agenda is we're going
to start and spend the first part of the
the conversation talking amongst the the
panelists I've got some questions for
them and I'm encourage them to question
and react to one another and then the
last 30 minutes basically from 15 to
2:45 we'll open it up and
and you can pepper them with your with
your questions all right so let me just
say a little bit about framing the the
topic and the question of building a
distinct company culture so the
underlying premise is that a distinct
culture is important to the success of a
new venture in that entrepreneur or
successful entrepreneurs are very
deliberate about creating and building a
culture that supports their success
there are strategists who will tell you
that in order for a culture to actually
be a source of competitive advantage it
needs to have three three different
things one it's got to be valuable to
the organization a source of cost-saving
differentiation and revenue it's got to
be rare the unique piece and third it's
got to be difficult to imitate or copy
otherwise anybody could do it so what
I'd like to do is just give the
panelists a chance to start out I just
say a little bit about your yourself and
your company and and tell us how would
you describe and how do people generally
describe the culture of your your
organization and how is that related to
its competitive strategy so I could just
go down from the right or is anybody
burning - I think Scott kind of got
nominated by Amy originally to go first
so we'll jump around Cole called I
haven't been back in a long time to get
cold call so my background is primarily
as a technologist so I've been a
co-founder in three publics three public
companies two software companies and one
telecommunications company and I'm now
CEO of a fourth which is venture funded
stealth and I can tell you that the big
epiphany I had prior to coming to
business school I had founded two
companies and both companies grew quite
large hundreds and hundreds of people
different locations and one of the
experiences I had before I came was I
visited an outlying office that we had
and I remember sitting in a meeting and
about halfway through it all I could
think was how did these people get in my
company it what I realized was that the
core group that we had started with was
something that reflected the core values
of the founders in in a big way and as
the company grew very quickly we lacked
the
methodology and the and the structure so
that the culture could remain consistent
as the company grew and at that moment
when when we thought about creating a
new company one of the things that
became very important was trying to
create a culture that I wanted something
that was durable and something that was
scalable so we actually spent a lot of
time in that process of you know trying
to come up with something that fit for
all the founders and in terms of
creating value maybe it would take too
long to share everything in the first
blush but I can tell you that you know
the last company Fiber Tower which
became a public company as well we had
the lowest turnover in the industry by
far in our segment we paid our average
salary was at the 50th percentile you
know compared to compared to our peers
and you know the employee satisfaction
the level of productivity we got out was
really just great so you know there are
very tangible benefits to investing in
culture some of which you can create
some of which are basically by virtue of
your actions and so forth but the net is
you're going to get a culture either way
but we try to be more premeditated about
doing it at farmer's hour and if you
were to sort of think of the just one or
two characteristics that really like ok
this is what's really different about
our culture what so probably the single
biggest thing is we became I guess
passionate about feedback while we were
here at the GSB so touchy feely the how
many of you or GSB alums that have taken
that and we all had been in somewhat
bureaucratic environments previously and
saw feedback institutionalizing it as a
method of being able to increase the
velocity of decision making reduce
bureaucracy and ultimately resolve
issues before they come big so we spent
a lot of time implementing a feedback
structure throughout the company and it
grew with the company and quite frankly
we use it in our new company as well I
think that was probably the single most
impactful tool we had at addressing
issues when they came up immediately and
not letting them fester my name is Amy
Pressman I'm the co-founder and
president of a company called Medallia
we are a technology company that
provides technology that kind of wires
really large organizations
their voice of the customer so we
collect feedback we track social media
and we tell the companies how they're
doing and we a couple things about us
we're bootstrap so we have not taken a
dime of money were a little bit smaller
than probably some of the other people
here at the table but we grew to 25
million so far without taking any any
money and I think I didn't think about
culture at all when we were started I
think most startups unless you have
really really crazy co-founders probably
have pretty good cultures because just
by their nature you've got a bunch of
people who are you know they're totally
energized by an idea they're coming
together maybe they're in a garage they
want to change the world maybe they'll
make a lot of money at the same time
it's kind of a motivating empowering
thing and people tend to have fairly
good cultures and then you hear a pretty
typical story that you know they meet a
lot of milestones and with each
milestone you know they'll get more
money more professionals will come in
and somehow the culture isn't quite the
same as it was back when we were 10
people are back when we were 50 people
so I think we were much the thing we
didn't think much about our culture we
did have similar very low turnover very
high employee satisfaction scores we've
won awards for being one of the best
workplaces but I would say the two
things that really really made me think
about culture are this number one we
were when we because we were
bootstrapping we didn't have we didn't
have a full fledged team when we started
so we ended up hiring a head of sales
about five years into our existence and
he brought with him a sales team and
they came all from another company so
it's almost like it's a little bit like
a mini merger and you take the culture
of one company and then you sort of
grafted on to our company and we did the
same thing with our marketing team
we hired a head of marketing who ended
up bringing a bunch of people from her
company and and it is when you start to
see these juxtaposition of various
cultures that you start to realize oh
this is what our culture is and this is
how it's different from other cultures
so that was one
you know one one thing that made me
really aware of it I think the other
thing is that we because of the product
that we have which is customer
experience tracking and because we were
unknown startup we went out and sold our
product to some really well-known brands
and the company is it turned out that
wanted us or companies that cared very
much about the customer experience and
we're willing to take a chance on an
unknown startup and those tended to be
most admired companies so we have this a
plus list of customers we have things
like Apple Retail and retail we have
Four Seasons in hotels we've got
companies that care deeply about the
customer experience and we decided that
we were going to go out and see what
they did and we not only looked at these
companies and our customers sort of at
the company level and at a brand level
we also because we track their customer
experience scores we went to the highest
performing outlets for example Gold's
Gym the highest performing Gold's Gym
Outlet the highest performing hotel
Hilton Hotel and we sat down and we
talked to their general managers and we
started to find a really consistent
thing and that is that they had
extremely strong cultures that the
management spent an incredible amount of
time nurturing and what I realized is
all companies have cultures whether you
decide to focus on it or not your
company will have a culture what when
you when you spend a lot of time on it
and you align the way that you hire the
way that you train the way that you fire
the way that you promote reward when
ever when you align all that it becomes
an organizing structure it becomes it's
almost in lieu of a lot of levels of
management and it makes you much more
nimble because what you're doing is
you're hiring you're articulating a
culture you're hiring people in that
agree with it and then you're you're
able to kind of let them loose and your
your your much more productive you're
much more effective so anyway this is
not just this was based on looking at
some of the best companies and some of
the best performing units in those
companies and they all did the same
thing so there was like we want to do
that and especially if we're selling
this we got to be able to do it so we've
spent a lot of time now trying to
emulate them and I have to say we're not
quite as good as some of our customers
but we're trying hard
so it sounds like though it so based on
your background one attribute or quality
of your your company and and what given
what you do
I could imagine would be analytical I
mean you know BCG in your background and
almost said Morgan Stanley Goldman Sachs
so is that part of your culture what you
value that kind of analytical lens and
then the other thing that I hear when
you talk about your clients is sort of
valuing of the high performers or the
elites are either of those things that
you think are distinctive about your I
think something that's really there are
a couple things that are really
distinctive about us one is we truly
truly do not hire and we will
fire them pardon my we will we will let
go of high performers who who are
corrosive I mean I believe very strongly
in this sort of dominance of a team
versus individual superstars I say the
other one is you know kind of our mantra
is no mediocrity no mediocrity for our
customers we want to help them become
great companies no mediocrity for our
team
so we're this interesting mix of super
high performance but a really nice group
of people and so I think that for the
right person that really resonates for a
lot of people it doesn't they don't want
to have anything to do with us but for
the right group of people it feel like
well this is a great place I can really
strive and yeah I don't I don't I feel
like everybody's got my back that's what
like the Stanford MBA class I think you
know the faculty certainly I'm sure
we're influential supporting them the
Knights people and really really bright
so that was a joke okay let's say do you
want to sure Hussain Raman I'm the CEO
and founder of a company called jawbone
for those of you that don't know us we
are I think according to our friends at
Goldman Sachs now the largest privately
held venture back consumer electronics
company in the world very quietly we're
backed by Sequoia Khosla Ventures
andreessen horowitz arm and you know
we've had a long interesting ride I was
actually an undergrad here in the
engineering school back in the mid 90s
and we started the company started
working ideas and sort of 97-98
really formed the company in 99 and
culture has been an interesting thing
for us because we've had you know many
sort of ups and downs to the point where
you know one point in 2005 the doors
were actually chained and we were nearly
out of business and we sort of bounced
back from that and continued to growth
so I you know I would say that a big
part of our culture has been sort of
this perseverance total belief in the
mission and what we're trying to
accomplish we like to think of ourselves
as being in the taste business as well
so design and being designed driven is
is a huge part of that um so I'd say
it's sort of perseverance design driven
and in making hard decisions that often
don't feel like they are the exact right
financial decision I'll give you guys an
example so we make things we make lots
of things in China and you know we use
medical grade plastics and all our
products it costs six times more than
what a lot of your typical consumer
electronics products to so to an Asian
manufacturer that is an insane decision
right they think we are totally batshit
crazy sorry for my language and and it
is a fight and we have to say no you got
to do this you got to do that or the
draft angles and and we focus on that
and we ended up winning design of the
decade from the IDSA for those decisions
and and people value that and that's why
we can sell products at higher premiums
better gross margins we avoid the
commoditization cycle that you see with
a lot of other consumer electronics
products so it all sort of comes
together these sort of perseverance and
fighting for hard decisions as well as
you know staying true the value of
having a great taste experience in
things like jasmine so andrew Houser I
was founder and currently founder and
co-ceo of freedom Financial Network and
bills.com which are two sister companies
that help people with financial
challenges started in 2003 shortly after
I graduated from the GSB in 2002 with my
friend and co-founder brad stroh
and it's we've grown from a spare
bedroom to about 550 close to 600
employees today and I've been able to
watch the evolution of the culture of
the creation of the culture from the
very start and I think just listening to
your intro you know you talked about
what is unique or what is rare
and what's interesting is thinking about
that there's nothing that's really
unique and rare in theory right I could
go and cut and paste someone's mission
vision and values and put them on my
website and call them my own and that
wouldn't do me a whole lot of good
what's what's unique and rare is living
it and believing in it that's hard
I can I can take any seven values in the
world if I don't believe in them and I
don't live them every day and that's not
really gonna do me a whole lot of good
and I think that is the challenge for
any entrepreneur it's constant we talked
about constancy consistency every single
day you have to be living those values
you have to be living with what you tell
your employees you care about and you
can never be off you know they say they
say a a cook is judged by their worst
meal I like to say a leader is judged by
their worst interaction you know you
walk in every day for 200 days and you
live your values and you say what you
need to say about your customers about
your employees and then on the 201st day
you walk in and you make some offhand
comment about your employees or about
your customers that's the comic people
are gonna remember and that one comment
can undermine years of work so you talk
about responsibilities we talk about
accountability we talk about getting
good people in the door getting bad
people out of the door but if you just
talk about it and you don't actually do
it you don't give people the
responsibility you don't hold people
accountable you don't get that I won't
use the word I'll be the only person in
the tailor doesn't swear in the intro
for the culture but if you don't live
that then you don't have a culture so so
so let me ask this what I mean I think
on this issue of living it what are the
things the specific behaviors routines
things that you do on a regular basis to
reinforce and to create that that
culture I mean so what does it actually
look like if we were to you know follow
you around with a camera for you know a
month what would be the kinds of
interactions events things that really
reflect
where the culture is created in your
organization's and any what it I was
thinking about
there's informal ways and there's
formalized and you know informally for
example we have an office in Phoenix
with about 350 employees I go there once
a month for a few days to a week a month
and when I walk in I walk around the
entire office it's now enormous its
80,000 square feet and I say hi to
everyone and try to shake as many hands
as I can when I first walk in it seems
like a relatively basic thing but I I've
gone so many so much feedback both
direct and indirect on how much it means
to these people that have me just walk
in and ask them how things are going
it takes me you know maybe an hour that
first day that I'm in in the office an
hour to two hours just to walk around to
all 350 people say hi say good morning
what's the latest
those are informal things informally
just just the decisions you make to get
rid of people the communications you
have but then there's the formal things
you know we do we stole a page out of
the Stanford's book we have brown bag
lunches every month where I get in the
room about this size and anyone that
wants to bring their lunch comes by and
asks me whatever question they want we
do we do we have a founders corner or an
intranet every weekly update with news
and and and things that that you know
back up that those values and and and
our vision that we're trying to create
so both both formally and informally in
your reactions every day and every week
help support that I think we're going
through a process right now we're we're
just over a hundred people were like 110
people and we need to be much more
proactive about our culture so what
we've done is we took our corporate
vision which we worked on about a year
ago and then we've worked out all our
values and then we kind of refresh the
values with a new crop of people and
then we go to each department head and
we say what is your department head
mission and then make sure that that's
relating to the corporate mission and
then what are your metrics how do you
know what does this look like at the end
of the year and how do you know that
you've succeeded what's a you know
you've hit it out of the ballpark what
is you know
single just and then and then we need
and in some cases we meet monthly in
some cases we need you know every city
every quarter and we just see you know
are you on track if you're not on track
is is there a problem or do we have the
wrong metrics but you're kind of telling
you you're getting everybody to define
and really really concrete terms what
their role is specifically in supporting
that overall mission and then you are
giving them a way to see how they're
doing and feel accountable for it and so
it kind of it kind of makes the whole
organization come together and I always
find these conversations a little bit
theoretical so one of my favorite
examples is the best Gold's Gym and the
Gold's Gym System happens to be in the
middle of Washington State and the guy
who runs as you know that their mission
is to make their community the Wenatchee
Valley the fittest community in America
and and he and he and he's given each
department you know a role and he says
things like you know the front desk
people he says when you pick up the
phone
in less than two rings you are likely
helping somebody to be able to play with
their grandchildren in their 70s and
that takes a very kind of theoretical
you know Fitness before it's making it
really concrete it's it's making its
visual it's making it a powerful story
and suddenly it's not about answering
the phone
well it's about helping this person take
that first step toward fitness and
playing with their grandchildren and a
couple other things he does I don't know
if you guys know anything about the
fitness industry but some of their
sacred cows are you know they want to
lock you in they want you to pay a high
initiation fee they want to lock you in
with the longest contract possible they
want to make it really painful for you
to get out of that contract so if you
move you have to like fax in your new
residence papers or your new lease or
your new I mean they make it really
really hard this guy said is that
serving our mission of making this the
fittest community in America no what
would it take for us to get the results
that we need the retention that we need
without a lock up without high initiate
and they got rid of them I mean this is
unheard of independent they are still
one of the highest performing gyms and
and I think when you walk in the door of
that gym as a customer as a prospective
customer you feel that these people want
to help you on your journey and they're
not just kind of cleaning up the
machines that is a totally different
experience from your average gym so I
mean this is this is a really concrete
example of what it means to have that
culture and the people he will fire
people he's not interested in people
necessarily having super toned bodies
although he himself has but he wants
people who care very much about other
people convey that and really buy into
that mission it's extraordinarily
powerful so that's just a concrete
example that I find very inspiring I
mean and I kind of bet that it's pretty
hard to get that attitude and those
practices to diffuse throughout the
other bullets Jim it's interesting I
mean in my experience is the only job
I've ever had so you know and we
interact with lots of different kinds of
companies big ones like AT&T and smaller
ones that are you know application
partners of ours and things like that
startups five people to you know
Deutsche Telekom which has 250,000
people and you see it's sort of a wide
range of cultures and I think that the
the thing that I've realized is that
each culture and each company has to be
appropriate for that company so it's
really hard to take something that you
see as a best practice somewhere else
and try to impose that into your
organization we do this a lot too it was
interesting to hear you talk about you
know lots of people coming in from the
outside obviously as you've grown under
scale you hire people who have had jobs
in other places and you can't grow
everyone from the internal organization
so the first thing I tell all the exec
shires so forget everything you learned
in all those other places your
experience is about helping us not make
the same mistakes but it's a totally new
playbook and let's not even think about
the things that we did in the past we
have to sort of have the appropriate
systems and culture for where we are
today doesn't mean that we don't have
values that have sort of permeated us
for a long time and you have to live it
and the way you live it I think changes
as the company changes as the company
grows as you get international
you know multiple offices and places you
have to do different things all the way
along and constantly watching it and
evolving with it and do what's
appropriate for your organization cuz
it's not gonna be the same for different
people depending on your product or your
service or any of those things so that's
important now I'll give you example from
our from our past we you know we make
these headset products and and a lot of
our customers like AT&T they make you
put your device into their standardized
packaging which reduces a lot of the
differentiation you get or the way you
can explain and tell the story around
what you're doing and it was a huge
fight for us because we had worked it
into contracts that we would you know
get our own packaging and be able to do
our special thing at the point-of-sale
and there was a regime change
you know merger or things like that it
was a singular days became 18c all those
contracts went out the window and there
was a period of time where we didn't
actually have Java on products on the
shelf because we refused to our biggest
customer and they were trying to impose
their will in terms of making us fit a
certain way and and do a certain thing
and we just said no we're not gonna do
it and therefore we're not gonna sell
our product on your shelves that was a
hard decision it was our biggest
customer you can imagine what the
venture guys felt like at a board level
I thought we were crazy um but we sort
of had a long-term view and we said you
know what if you again allow this to
happen and and don't give us the ability
to be true to what our values are and
what we want to render stand for then
it's a slippery slope right and you've
got to have people on your team on your
board that are willing to go with you on
that that's hard so when I think about
you know what are the daily interactions
that you have that reinforce or describe
the culture of a company I gotta break
it down in two ways one is you know as
an individual as a CEO what interactions
do you have and what are the messages
that you give off but let me start first
with more the process side what are the
things that we do as a company that
everybody that comes through the company
experiences in a very consistent way so
first off is you know we did spend time
I guess like everybody sitting down and
deciding what what are the core values
that describe us that describe the
founders describe the company we want to
be describe the relationships we want to
have with us
we spent a lot of time trying to think
about this when we started to hire we
tried to convert those core values into
behavioral characteristics that we could
use to select the right people so when
looking at a group of very talented
people how do you select the people that
culturally are going to be the best fit
for you
so one of the things we do is evidence
in the company we train in a standard
methodology for recruiting we use a
behavioral interviewing process
everybody learns the language everybody
becomes accustomed to it and every
single person that comes into the
company goes through a rigorous rigorous
recruiting process where you know
everybody has everybody has a role in
the process its divvied up across an
entire interview team and then when that
when we finished the process when we
come back to talk about that particular
candidate we do it as a team and it is
we have literally call it gonna head the
decision at the end of the meeting is
gonna head are you or you said higher or
do you say not higher and it's unanimous
decision so everybody takes
responsibility for people that come into
the company because they played a direct
role in it and if the process is hard
what you find is that even though I may
not know you you may work in a different
office than I do if I know that you went
through the exact same rigorous process
I feel confident that you're good
because you went through the same the
same filter that I did
so once the employees come in the other
thing we talk about is wanting to be
able to evaluate and communicate how
people are doing so we're also less so
in the startup phase of this new company
but in the operations phase of fire
tower we were very rigorous about
defining the PP&E the the performance
evaluation structure we would use for
the people in the company and some of it
was company related objectives so it was
personal related objectives and most of
the personal objectives tied back to the
core values of the company but we would
tie compensation and we would tie more
even more importantly we would tie
equity to the high performers in the
company so one of the processes we used
to go through is we would stack rank
employees in the company and we would
disproportionately divvy up equity at
the end of every year so my goal was to
take a hundred percent of equity and
give eighty percent of it to the a
players and that just reinforced a
culture
of people that were trying to exceed
their own capabilities and then also
having a very humane way for people that
aren't working in the company to exit
them out of the company and a respectful
and you know reasonable process where
you know they just can't be part of your
organization and then you know things I
talked about earlier like feedback being
able to address issues in a very
straightforward way culturally for us
that was a big deal
so you would often see people leave a
meeting where it was a very civil
meeting but you know hard decisions need
to be made and they might grab somebody
a meeting and say you know I understand
what you were trying to do but this
behavior that you demonstrated was
inconsistent with that goal and you may
not have realized it at the time but if
you take it in the vein that that person
is there to help you be better at what
you do it's a very very productive
experience and and then I guess finally
I think it's the individual aspect what
do you do as an individual in a company
so I guess similar to Andrew we had 14
offices I used to travel to every office
on a regular circuit I would go visit
all 14 different offices in different
states and while I was there I would try
and pick a couple different positions
there and I'd spend a day with him so if
it was a field tech I'd spend the day in
the field with them if it was you know
one of our account managers I might go
visit some of their customers but I
wanted to make sure that I knew every
single role in the company what they did
and they knew that I knew that so that
when I was talking about that or when I
was experiencing them you know in terms
of evaluating them I had I had a greater
feeling for it and then the final thing
that we did was it's very difficult at
the top of a company to recognize the
really amazing things that happen and
what you find is they're they're heroic
things that happen every day that never
really get talked about so we
implemented a recognition process a sort
of an employee based recognition process
we called shout outs where any employee
in the company could give any other
person a recognition award and that
person would get it was just it was a
$50 gift certificate but the requirement
to do it is they had to draft an email
to the entire company and describe what
happened and we didn't we didn't make
that up we got that we stole that from
it was great because people had the
opportunity to hear even you know at
different levels in the company amazing
heroic things that were that were
happening and then the final thing was
creating transparency and we tried to
over communicate to the company so we
had a policy that after every board
meeting I would hold a company-wide
communication and I would share what was
described not all of it was always
positive but at least they knew exactly
where we stood so I never viewed my role
as a marketing role to the employees in
the company I viewed myself as sort of
providing the the current direction of
what we were doing and what was
important for us to be successful so
that was so let me just pick up on this
you know this feedback and again one of
things you're known for is your
credibility in the touchy-feely realm
high performance leadership but but I
don't think there's a kind of another
company here that wouldn't say no no we
really value giving honest and accurate
feedback but yet it's it's it's hard to
do what is it that you found to be kind
of most challenging about really living
consistently that that value of being
honest and constructive and providing in
providing feedback I mean why is it so
rare so first off the ironic thing is
I'm the only one on the team that didn't
actually take the class I actually took
it through executive to go figure out
what everybody was talking about it's a
process that requires continuity it's a
process that if you do it once it can be
very destructive so it's you know we
always looked at it as a method of being
able to you know in doing a start-up you
never know if you're gonna be successful
you know and if you look at the odds
it's it's uncanny how many of them
actually fail so we viewed it as a
process that even if we did the best we
could and the company didn't work we
wanted to be better professionals better
individuals better executives better
whatever it was and we viewed this as a
process for ourselves so in many ways it
was a very selfish process because it
was a way for us to get feedback from
people that we really respected the
hardest part was
was was getting people to trust the
process so we we grew very quickly we
hired people from a lot of large
ironically wireless carriers we had to
CTO from one of the major carriers join
us and we would always give them a free
ride through the first feedback session
so I'd do an executive feedback session
and inevitably I would talk with them
afterwards and they would all go that
was really rough
you guys were tough on each other and
you know it was interesting because that
was a symptom of the fact that even
though everything was being discussed
needed to be discussed and it was done
in a very frank and maybe too efficient
way he had never experienced that in
where he came from there was always the
superficial aspect of communication the
360 evaluation the review that comes
from a boss but not something that's
very specific so for us when we did a
feedback it was three positives three
negatives and every single one that you
did had to be backed up by a specific
example you had to say in this situation
you did this and here was the way that I
perceived your behavior you can't argue
with that and the goal was not to argue
with the goal was to take that because
that was that person's perspective you
may disagree with it but that was what
they felt and I think so implementing
this was training the people how to do
it being having the continuity that it
would happen on a continuous repeatable
basis and then building the trust that
it wasn't done to you know as an
offensive weapon against somebody but it
was really done this the value was for
you so for example for us
HR never attended a feedback session not
a single comment that ever was given and
feedback affected your actual pay or
equity in the company it was purely for
you so it was just a way that we
interpreted that particular technique
okay thanks so let me ask Andrew a
different question I sort of thought
about some questions based on the
particular challenges that that that the
organization's by face how do you think
about or deal with the clash between
your company's culture and how you think
about what you're doing and then maybe
the industry values philosophy or
culture right so in consumer credit
certainly during
period of time it was you know spend
spend spend you know borrow borrow oral
and to the extent that you're really
trying to operate differently in that
context how do you protect your
organization from the philosophy in the
in the industry yeah that's a very
fitting question are not just a consumer
credit in general which is as we all
know had some some issues over the past
several years but our industry in
particular when we started the company
it was an innovative idea of way of
working out consumer debts outside of
the context of a bankruptcy we were one
of the few people doing it we became the
industry leader but it was a classic low
barrier to entry business that resulted
in the flood of competitors especially
after all the mortgage people went out
of business they jumped into our
industry so there became a very big
disconnect between what we were saying
we're doing for customers and our core
values and our belief that we're this
white knight here to help consumers and
we'll do anything to help our customers
and it's a very emotional high touch
product and the rest of the industry not
all of the industry but certainly what
got picked up in the press a very very
big disconnect it actually to many
details but we want up because we're the
industry leader in the industry started
to get a bad name we wound up getting
sued by the state of California and so
here we are having built this culture
around belief in our employees belief in
what we're doing taking care of
customers helping people through this
difficult emotional point in their life
and all of a sudden the state of
California is suing us and saying that
we're taking advantage of consumers yeah
that's a pretty to beat different things
we're helping consumers through this
emotional period we're taking advantage
of consumers by the state of California
said so how do we deal with that it's
difficult but communication is
extraordinarily important yeah be you
can't spin that right it's in the news
it's on TV it's on blogs your
competitors are
selling against it everyday so you're
not spinning it you're being open and
honest you're communicating every day
every week it was an emotional period
for us but I think you know part of it
is your your belief which is contagious
true belief and what you're doing is
contagious right it is if people see
that you really are passionate what
you're doing if you're believing in what
you're doing they're gonna believe in it
and it starts with the founders but then
it goes to you know the next level down
that's right that's really really
important it's getting good people in
the door early as an entrepreneur those
are your ambassadors that are gonna
carry your message to the rest of the
company and you know how do you get a
good people as a startup that's that you
know that is a crucial question because
it's going to pay dividends for four
tough events like this but so
communication consistency honesty and
then having a really strong management
team that truly believes in what they're
doing and am i correct my recollection
of the case that it was written about
pretty financial is that you actually
sort of bought this suit you no longer
and harder than some of your advisers
would have regular we'd like to just
settle later let it go and you you
didn't you kind of persevered and
contested again yeah that's correct give
you but that was a tough there was a
case written which some of you may have
read and yeah in the new ventures or one
of the entrepreneurship classes the key
decision at the time was okay we have
state of California Italians were doing
all these bad things we have millions of
dollars and potential litigation
expenses coming up we have the press and
when a regulator you know this is
something that they don't teach enough
about in business school especially in
this environment what regulation is
everywhere when a regulator decides
they're coming after you it's not just a
negotiation it's they're calling the ABC
station the NBC station they're trying
to do everything in their power to sort
of press you into a settlement and so we
have this you know this decision to make
do we just settle this to pay a lot of
money except that we did something wrong
and move on or do we fight this and try
to deal with the consequences to employ
morale to public relations
to our competitors ability to sell
against us and we ultimately decided to
fight it because we I mean that was this
is what we've been telling our managers
all along we are not doing anything
wrong we believe in what we're doing
we're helping people sure there's
knuckleheads in our industry but we're
doing the right thing and we've
ultimately decided that if we turned
around and just agreed okay yeah we're
doing something wrong we'll get out of
the state of California we'll pay all
this money and find that that would send
the wrong message you know and
economically it was a tough decision but
in the long run it certainly was the
right decision yeah did you win we want
I mean we settled very favorably I would
say it did not actually go to trial but
this settlement was extraordinarily
favorable with we didn't have to change
any business which is very on you're
good for settlement yeah it's clear oh
can I say one thing about the feedback
cuz I can't actually stress enough I
mean we've learned this lesson the hard
way because you to get through some of
the the tough times we had we built deep
friendships with people in the
organization and as you scale quickly
some of those people don't scale with
you but yet you're close to them and
they're friends and the thing that I
learned the hard way was that if you
don't give people straight direct
complete feedback it is much worse than
if you thought you could manage it and
sort of package it in a way um and the
thing that we do I think well now that
we never did before not quite as
organized and the way the you guys do
but we tell people look this feedback is
coming to you for one reason and one
reason only which is that it's to make
you better so we can succeed as an
organization it's the only reason you're
giving the feedback because if you're if
you're not getting the feedback it means
we don't care anymore and that's that's
a bad problem right so I think if you
start those conversations with that sort
of mindset that the reason we're doing
this is it's an investment if you don't
understand that it's a way of sort of
working through that people appreciate
that right who doesn't want to sort of
be able to look in the mirror and really
understand and and sometimes the folks
just don't do it well so I think
establishing that right up front that it
is about being better in about
everyone so let me follow up on that and
actually ask any question because you're
in the business in part of helping your
clients to use feedback from customers
to make to make them to make them better
and so how do you influence the culture
of your clients so that they are really
using the data in the way that they
should be and not biasing it and I'll
tell a little anecdote of my experience
recently actually a number of times with
18t which I don't remember whether they
were client or not so but but so they're
clearly getting lots of feedback and you
know I was on the phone three or four
times trying to correct you know some
issue and at the end I always got if I
answered all your questions
because you're gonna be getting a survey
and I really want you to be able to give
me an A+ or an H or whatever it was when
they call you for the survey and I you
know I certainly felt kind of coerced
into that I'm like well if that's what
they're doing is that data really
meaningful so how do you influence the
culture in your clients we try and share
best practices we host a best practices
conference once a year and we bring all
of our clients together a lot of them
get up and give presentations in the
example that you gave it is absolutely a
worst practice to to in any way try and
skew the results of a survey and in fact
in the case of Apple retail you will be
fired if you even so much as tell a
customer that they might get the survey
you can't even mention it you can't
mention so you know we try we try and
show that we have this concept of all
companies say they care about the
customer experience maybe 10 percent
really care about it you know another 40
percent or kind of so may care about it
and then a lot of them don't really care
they just have to it's like motherhood
and apple pie and so we have this
concept of believers seekers and then
non-believers and I guess our feeling is
we try and share the best practices of
the believers the ones who have shown
they really understand it and some and
some will gravitate and then you know we
really work closely with the Seekers to
help
and then you know and at the end of the
day we feel better if if if somebody
gets a you know ten percent better and
their don't become the absolute best
that's still ten percent better so I
mean we we sort of help people wherever
they are on that journey but you know we
extend we we don't lower our prices we
don't so we end up with a heavily skewed
toward the believers because we have the
best product but the functionality that
we have is most interesting to people
who really care about this versus people
who are paying lip service to it well
one interesting thing about our product
and the topic of culture is we're
talking about this before the started
stories are like an incredible part of
the culture the stories about the
founders and you were mentioning one but
one thing that we found with our
customers is we have there's always a
question that's an open-ended question
and you get these really precious
customer comments from time to time and
some of them become you know just legend
in the organization so it's so you you
stop getting just the co-founder stories
or the you know the superstar employee
stories you start getting the customer
stories this customer had this
experience you hear these like for
example about Nordstrom what Nordstrom's
employees will do for their customers
and so we found that our platform
ironically does strengthen culture as
those as the things become almost urban
legends within an organization that's
great okay so last question then we'll
open up for the same so the jawbone is
known for cutting edge and this is a
quote cutting edge design coming up with
products that people don't know they
need but then they can't live without
I'm like wow that's great absolutely I
want one of those but so this sounds a
lot like a culture of innovation
engineering you know design being ahead
of customers but it seems like there are
lots of stories that the danger of that
kind of culture is that you could become
insular and insensitive to customers and
it's kind of like you know well we know
best
you know you'll know what you want when
we tell you what it is and then you you
sort of
lose your market how do you either
balance that protect against that
possibility and think about you know we
want to listen but we also want to push
it's a great question I think that's a
friend that's an existential challenge
for a company like us right because so
much of what we do especially as we
pushing the new categories of new
markets you're looking around a corner
and you're trying to guess what people
want so we do it's on multiple different
vectors it's also in terms of how do we
manage our investment against those new
things and sort of take it step by step
and phase test something see if it works
go behind it so a little bit of what we
call chasing model so if it's working
really well we double down and then push
into it so those those are kind of just
you know financial risk things that we
do but you know fundamentally I think
that what we try to do is innocent sort
of the way we build products actually is
we make a map and we don't do em or DS
or PR DS or do those things we don't do
focus groups we don't do any of it we
basically sit around and there's a core
group of about six people in a company
who work on this and we make a map of so
here's the way the world works today
with all the kinds of devices that we
interact and where are the friction
points in the way that we use these
devices or other people maybe you can
get a lot of data from customers and
people around where the friction points
what are the things that don't work
where would you know what they have to
push a button here or take that thing
out or whatever and then we start to say
okay well if we could solve that problem
and of a you know do we need to push the
silicon guys or do we build networking
technology that supports it and then we
start to push on all those different
threads and say you know and then when
we build stuff we say how are we
resolving it again solves against this
experience continuum and ultimately it's
about making using technology make
things easier for people a lot of
communicating places they didn't do
before things like that and so that's
that's one of the ways from a product
perspective you try to solve it we say
it's about making things easier and
resolving experiences wouldn't it be
great if you could do this so it is a
little bit Star Trek II or winery
important stuff but it's fun and I think
that you're gonna make some mistakes for
sure and it's how you structure yourself
to iterate quickly
we almost died a few times and it just
changes so so we have a sort of
multi-headed system attack anyone had
something on that cuz our cup of our
customers use it two ways there are two
components one is service and one is
product and on the service side a lot of
our companies they have strong cultures
so they delegate a lot of responsibility
to their front lines and then and they
don't micromanage like some franchise
organizations you'll go into and you'll
feel like you're getting the scripted
did you find everything you needed and
you know but others you actually have a
real conversation so we tend to serve
those groups and what happens is
different people try different things at
different you know different stores or
different banks or whatever it is and
then on our system you start to see it
customer satisfaction the spiking
customer satisfaction is dropping what's
going on here turns out this manager
came up with a really innovative you
know a really innovative solution to a
problem I've got a great example I'm
gonna try and camouflage who it is but
basically the customer satisfaction
across this company tanked and one guy
looked at it and he realized that
salesperson and rude kept coming up with
the low scores on a particular product
so he asked the sales people and they
said yeah it's off warranty and
everybody's really pissed off when they
find out it's off warranty so he told
them when they came to work the next day
they all own this particular product
themselves he took it from them per day
and he gave it back 24 hours later and
customer satisfaction in that store
spiked because now people came in with
this product off warranty and all of the
sales reps that they ran into said that
sucks that happened to me the other day
I am so sorry bad news is we don't you
know it's off warranty the good news is
I could and it was the same message
delivered with genuine empathy and that
was it and you can and it was like a
brilliant smart front my thing and then
somebody at corporate saw this spike
when and found out what it was told the
rest of the organization scores went up
everywhere so you know so that's on the
server side of it so while listening
right you got a warning but there's also
allowing people
or on the front in the front lines
communicating with the marketplace to
use their judgment and and deal with the
nuance of the other on the product side
Hyatt is one of our customers and they
they started a new concept Hyatt Place
for like the 30-something business
travellers and they did a whole bunch of
focus group so they're gonna get rid of
things like the front desk and all these
things that are sort of standards in
hotels and then they put it out there
with us and they were just monitoring
they were trying they had a couple of
hotels and they were trying you know
should we serve this kind of food or
that kind of food in terms of the
products I and just really really
tracking it and being very innovative
and quickly changing if it wasn't
working and and so just being very very
nimble about how they and not expecting
to get it 100% right when they rolled it
out even though it was so you know I
think it comes down to the listen if
ways to get that listening and feedback
well on that note I think we should
listen to our front lines here so if
there are questions and raise your hand
and if you want to address it to a
particular panelist or any panelists
just note that so let's start over here
on the right and it's really you know
very early stages you mention
so we find you stuck trying to read
about culture and then you understand me
on HR but it was at that moment that we
stopped worrying about survival time for
culture are just trying time yeah I
think it starts from the very first hire
I mean whether you like it or not it's
happening so you know I think that one
good thing about the GSB is that you do
relative to other business schools I
think people come out of here with a lot
of OB classes that you feel you know
people do care about it here and it's it
is a great thing you know we came out
and we said I don't know what it means
but I want to create a good culture yeah
from the very first day and I think part
of that is a little bit the GSB is
influenced but then I wouldn't say it's
HR HR is an administrative function
culture comes from I agree you can't
delegate to HR but I think that your
hiring firing training it's so good
ministry should be a very important
function so yeah I talked to the
administrator coach our would make sure
you're complying with the laws and don't
want to get sued and that's HR and that
yeah I would never delegate the culture
they be hey we talked about it's never
his HR I would never delegate that to
the HR department right III agree with I
mean I think it starts from day one and
I think that you know it's really in my
personal experience you don't think
about it but there's no organization
that it doesn't have a culture right if
you don't care about it that much that's
a culture right it's it's a culture of
one type of thing I mean it's
interesting I see a lot of people who
are repeat entrepreneurs who become a
lot more disciplined about it in terms
of the systems and process they put on
it implementing right at the beginning
the second or third time or the fourth
time they do it and you know our
experience it absolutely starts with day
one
and think about it all the time because
for us I mean everything we do is based
on people which inherently ties back to
culture I actually we we stole a
practice from Zappos and if you guys are
interested in culture and you're in Las
Vegas take a tour of Zappos agree it's
great but what they do is they divide
their interviews into functional
interviews and and culture cultural fit
interviews because when you're in that
situation and you have that you know gap
to fill you start to look past those
little things that are signals that this
might not be a cultural fit and so if
you delegate that decision about
cultural fit to another group that has
no vested interest in feeling that
specific role then you kind of you're
you're you're and so we've we've done
that as well now so we and it's hard
it's really hard but you just have to
remind yourself it's much more painful
to hire the wrong person much more
painful I would say just to give using a
mistake as an example if I look back at
appearance when we needed to hire
quickly I there's a direct correlation
between those periods and not hitting
the quality that we wanted to get you
can literally see these pockets of men
that was a bad sales training class oh
that was when we need we're trying to
hire 20 people in the week yeah it
direct correlation so that would suggest
we didn't have the answer for your
question but it is certainly a problem
yeah I think the way a good way to
address that when you're in rapid rapid
growth is if you get the right kind of
senior leadership team and they're
bought in the culture and they're bought
into the mission they can also sort of
disseminate that and spread insulae if
you get the right few key hires in the
in the kind of
it becomes a domino if anything's right
and that helps you move along faster
because good people will often bring
other good people with them and they
will all sort of figure out how to get a
line with what you're trying to do if
you set that out as something that you
want them to do so you get some leverage
from having a tell you know it's
interesting I don't think behavioral
characteristics
I guess there's different types of
diversity so maybe we should be clear I
mean there's no its cultural diversity
there's there's experienced diversity
there's a lot of different types of
diversity out there so I don't think the
types of things that we we we look for
behaviorally affect the traditional
forms of diversity and I if you look
across the companies that you know
particularly fiber teller and our new
company it's incredibly heterogeneous in
terms of people with their backgrounds
you know cultures languages everything
is very very energies but what you're
really trying to do I think where the
behavior where this behavioral
interviewing works is you're trying to
look across this melting pot of people
and find the common denominators and
allow you the victim to knit them
together into something that's very
cohesive so the real goal you're trying
to do is not to and not to remove that
the heterogeneity but rather focus on
the homogeneous things that you need to
be successful and bring that together so
I think it's kind of the opposite of the
way you're thinking about it
in terms of you know I think there's
consensus you know you've got a higher
ease you've got higher people
all of that means that are done you know
you got a look at the realities of
market there's just a short-term good
talents everybody and so you need to you
know sometimes make our decisions and
it's not because it's going to go away
in a week or a month maybe their waters
years anything you could do mean yes
people like to be a good cultures but
then some other companies also have
cultures so so how do you how do you be
the stress market
I think that there's a couple of the
nuances to your question I mean I think
that so I'll start with an example I
mean a talent for one for fur andrew is
very different than a talent from me
right and a talent in one part of the
organization is very different than a
talent in a different part of the
organization and the way we think about
it is that when we find the right people
we often wonder what we did without them
right and that's always the best sort of
measurement of like you know where your
organization is and I so I think that
you know a lot of it depends on a
mentality of what a person wants to do
and I see lots of wonderful candidates
all the time where you know I wish it
was more of a fit and I wish that you
know if we're competing against Facebook
for a software application engineer that
they would rather work on a business
that has that software but also has a
device versus just you know social
network so a lot of it is is also the
choice of the other person and it comes
back to what is the opportunity are they
aligned with it do they believe in the
vision they believe in the story of
where you're going do they think they
can have a material impact on that story
and that and that to me is fundamentally
how you compete is focusing in on your
story it also helps with alignment but
also helps attract the right talent in
that kind of does that make sense talk
about culture we clearly all care
passionately about it but talking about
good culture it's like talking about
good education when you really get down
to it everybody has a very different
definition of what it is and so what I
found this is a problem for us but if we
find someone that we think is a cultural
fit and we get them in for they talk to
it at least three maybe two people then
they just want to join because they're
feeling that cultural fit too right it's
okay if you've ever worked in an
environment or with a team or been in a
situation where you just totally feel
and flow and you feel like you're
getting that then it's like you you want
to be there it's it's it's like this
resonates with me I'm so so an ultra
financial upside for that in my
experience the good people will trade
potential financial upside for that
yeah it sounds more important to that
but the challenge especially for a much
smaller company like ours is to get them
to talk to us a couple of times but but
you know slowly but surely you start to
get word-of-mouth going out and and we a
lot of our hires are like your friends
of friends and you know and they heard
about us and you know so I stick with it
you'll find people that that really just
totally buy into exactly what you want
to do and that's an awesome feeling one
other thing I'd add we do a lot of crazy
stuff that when we find the right
candidate I mean but one of my biggest
shareholders Vinod Khosla
and you know you suppose they clean
second billion years is consumer
electronics company Vinod actually was
on vacation with his family and he got
his plane and flew to meet a VP
candidate of mine just on his holiday
because it was that important right or
I'll have them me and there I mean
there's we will call people ten times in
a day and just not be embarrassed about
it right and so those are little things
that we do that if we think somebody's
right and it does feel good
we're just not gonna take no for an
answer we often say that know is just
one step on the path to yes but on one
thing that wasn't directly said other
was indirectly said is that good people
attracted people stars attract stars
right the early people in your door need
to believe passionately what you're
doing carry that in that torch of the
culture because when you when you go
into an office for an interview and you
meet a bunch of people who think the
same way you do or are good people or
fun who look like you know I want to
work with those people it's that it is
the people that drive the cultures the
people that attract and retain good
people so those first few hires are
pretty damn crucial for you total
you wanna make me feel special and
obviously that comes before maybe you've
been a pitcher program - you do penny do
you guys any thoughts in terms of how to
keep preparing special instead of
entitlement over time I talked to some
folks there Microsoft has let me put
away the top servers for a period of
time just would love to get your
thoughts on move out of the Bay Area Bay
Area it's a tough culture cuz people are
used to think pay will be treated well
there's a high competition for labor so
how you know how do we I mean I am being
serious in Phoenix when we do something
like a monthly luncheon people love it
people I get I get I get 20 thank you
emails we do it in San Mateo it's okay
whatever lunch give me something more
than lunch please yeah but I think you
should change up the programs you know
cuz things do get stale it's like you
can't keep selling the same service or
product forever some people can but um
they they get stale and and I think in
the same way you have to change programs
evolve what's relevant it's an
opportunity for innovation just like in
any other part of your organization but
what about if you're changing them up
and you take something away right it's
like okay well we're not gonna give you
a free lunch anymore but we're gonna
give you free pallets right but that's a
people are pissed off you go you go to
serve a manwich you gotta say this is
why this thing is better for you right
we're in a situation right now where
we're actually it's a kind of a funny
story we're movie we've got a pretty
healthy sort of PTO policy and it's
funny because the top performers are way
over accrued on on PTO and and just you
know
yeah we're getting rid of all PT land
and it's it's an interesting there's
like half the people love the fact that
we're getting rid of pto and other
people are freaked out by it and so you
got to communicate with them and explain
why this ultimately is better and it's
about accountability and so one thing
that we've done with with this is
slightly different than benefit like a
free lunch but with incentives a lot of
our groups are production based and we
have incentives and it's certainly true
that we've created some sales incentives
that have become more like obligations
than incentives we just expect that
we're gonna get this check every week
for doing this so what we've started to
try to do in the past couple years is
just set the expectation that because
it's gonna change every month or every
couple months and people know it's gonna
change an incentive influences
especially a short-term incentive a
monthly incentive weakening sendeth can
influence behavior only for so long
before it starts to get stale so how do
you prevent people from getting mad when
you take one away and give them another
just set the expectation that there's
gonna be constant change with respect to
those those benefits or incentives we
have a slightly different we weren't
moving more toward having these things
come from
you know the employees they're they're
all owners of the company and they
should act like owners so it's more like
along the lines of the transparency
we're pushing out more information
giving them a lot of information about
how we're doing how do we want to
allocate our budgets do we want to do
this do we want to do that and they find
when you give people responsibility for
making those decisions instead of it
being the company deciding which
benefits you will will not have it
really changes so an example as we just
moved offices and we are having people
can if they come from a different
country they can nominate themselves to
decorate one of the conference rooms
like their country and there was some
budget and I said just skip budgets
don't worry about budgets just be really
creative and you know and we may ask you
questions if we think about it people
got really upset they're getting really
freaked out they're like we don't want
to spend that much money you know we
want to pump the money into other parts
of the organization
and so that was that sense of ownership
you know this is my company and I'm not
really sure I'd love that response I'd
love that they you know it's like
instead of host like I'm gonna go buy a
Turkish carpet you know hey wait a
minute I thought it was great
that's cool yes senior leadership in the
organization to develop their micro
culture and they realize you haven't
used that one culture sounds like a
dysfunctional company that's the whole
purpose of all the things we're talking
about is to try and avoid that you want
to have common objectives you want to
have compensation plans that link the
company together you have to make sure
that every discrete part of the
organization has some vested interest in
everyone else being successful as well
so that's thank you makes the point like
we see it we have so many different
functional areas we would all be in
office in China right may have a
distinctly different culture and I give
you a funny story like I I went there
and we took a big office in Shanghai and
the guy that's the GM there had this 70
square metre office in our office it
just goes all open-plan
no offices everyone sits on the same
floor same deaths everything he knows
from very equal and flat here this 70
square metre office and I said it was
doing the 70 square metre office like I
don't know 70 square metre office and he
said while this is officer of Asian
cultures are and you know they need to
sort of see me I said look either like
not gonna have an office or you just
like blow out all these spaces and just
get conference rooms if you need to have
a private conversation you can go do
that in a conference room music well
it's it's unusual for for the way you
know people do is insane so I'm like I
don't care then they can go work at a
different company or you know
do business with us because we don't
have offices and they can decide to do
that so you've got it you've got to see
where it's right and where it can be
additive and the little micro culture
can help push the organization and where
it's just wrong it doesn't sort of
resolve itself to the core value you
just gotta squash it fast
I think that we struggle with this all
the time and and our answers we are
reorganizing and trying something one
thing that we're going to now is what if
we organize people in troops kind of
like the military six or seven people
troops because on the one hand we want
people to be really nimble and their
teams really close to each other care
deeply about each other but then we also
want them to collaborate across so we
had a vertical structure and decisions
had to go up before they got made and
that wasn't working so we reordered so I
I think if you're kind of paying
attention to it and you raise a great
issue sort of about as you expand
internationally and now you're
transporting your culture far away but
then you're also putting in a location
that's got too large a different macro
culture how are you
respectful of that macro culture in the
country in which you're opening a new
office but maintaining some essence of
who you are so I think you face that all
the time and I think to be aware of it
and to be willing to change things up
and how you structure and organize and I
think it's just trying to find the best
thing like other things we've learned
from our China operation that we're
trying to pull that back in California
chose to paste right and have a state
things relative to a we do so it's it's
a constant pushed and pull and and what
I try to tell people is try to take the
bat we weighed office in London they
have a totally different culture but in
Europe and they do in China and it's how
do you get all these people to have the
right kind attention and push the ball
and find the best in each thing and then
try to bring that up and have an image
contribute you know we we struggle with
that one too like that sort of the
engineer or God's kind of culture is
that what you're talking about a little
bit yes ma'am
yeah and there's gonna be there's
attention since it's good because
everyone has a different one I think
what you've got to do is make everyone
understand what their role is in the
greater good
and how they need to interoperate of
each other this is sort of a foundation
for process right of how they all work
together to push the whole thing for the
other thing that strikes me it's again
it's I go back to the beginning of the
conversation you all talked about the
distinctive features of your your
organization's in your culture there
were some aspects that really are
immutable like it's hard for me to
imagine you having a subculture no
matter where you are bringing what
industry where there was sort of a
predatory mindset it's like we just
wouldn't do that and it's hard for me to
imagine you know having you know people
who are like yeah we just need to butter
them up and don't we can get rid of them
you know being being not 4:3 and so it
seems like the kind of the kiyose
questions like well what really are the
most important defining characteristics
of your culture that you don't ever
compromise on and then what are things
that well you know we will have you know
different food in the London office
we'll have tea instead of coffee I think
to get to that you know talking about
functional teams when we talk we a big
difference between us our sales team
which in our industry are
stars highly compensated relatively
highly compensated and then customer
service we're fulfilling the product and
certainly yeah you know to your point
there's tension customer service people
said that salespeople are over-promising
how can I deliver the cuts salespeople
are saying I'm losing customers because
you're not supporting my customers
customer service people saying all these
tests people make so much money they go
on these trips and they do all this fun
stuff and they make these huge
incentives certainly we have that so so
how do we do that you know what yeah it
does come back to the culture whatever
is our fundamental goal our fundamental
thesis when we started this company is
that there is a hugely underserved
market of people that have financial
problems that the existing solutions out
there are either predatory are just not
that good and that we're gonna come in
with a solution that is ROI base for the
consumer where we get paid based on our
results and we are going to always do
what's in the best interest for that
client whether that's up front when
we're selling the client if they're not
right for our program guess what we'll
refer you we have a network of companies
if you should be refinancing your
mortgage
I'll refer you to a mortgage company if
you should be declaring bankruptcy we
have a nationwide network of attorneys
that will refer you to upfront we're
gonna do the right thing on the back end
the customer service we're always going
to do the right thing for that customer
you know we don't have average handle
times we don't say be off the phone in
two minutes or five minutes
stay on the phone as long as it takes to
resolve that customer machine so that
culture of always doing what's right
house with that conflict and you know
another thing that and I'll stop and let
other people go on but it is when you
have this tension that sometimes may be
between engineers and support or with
sales and support you know when a
customer service rep comes and complains
about the the generous compensation of
the sales you're free to apply for that
job total it is a tough that was my
first reaction yeah you know the
salesperson you're measured every day
it's like being an athlete you come to
work every day and your numbers are on
the board and if you don't work guess
what that's a very different job than
being a customer service agent if you
want to try it yeah you're free to try
it too
so let me I'm watching time and I
probably should have kind of punctuated
at this point and come to the sort of
closing part a little earlier but is
there anything that any insights about
culture or startups that you know remain
unsaid that you would just be not
satisfied if you didn't leave this group
with with that that last pearl so we've
got about five minutes maybe potentially
a little controversial but what I have
learned is the value of the team versus
the value of individuals and at the end
of the day if you're like me and you've
gone to great schools and you've gone to
business school and you've worked in
certain organizations unless you play
this team sport you know nothing about
teamwork
really you probably think you're doing
teamwork when you all huddle together
and divide up TAS run off to your TAS
come back together that's not teamwork
and I so I I think that and we hire a
lot of people just like me in our
company and so we're all learning to be
better true team players and I think a
book that was really influential for me
is called tribal leadership and it's by
a professor out of USC and he looked at
all these different organizations and
listen to the language that they had any
divided cultures into five different
cultures I won't bore you with it but it
really talks at the end of the day about
when you have true teamwork you get to a
stage where you're not you're not really
gonna have these interdepartmental
conflicts because everybody is going to
be working toward that same goal and he
finds that in only about 20% of
companies and the vast majority are in a
level where it's all about I'm great
others not so much they're about that
you know you you're you the ingoing
assumption is don't trust until they
earn your trust rather than trust until
they don't earn your trust the ingoing
assumption is to hold withhold
information rather than to share
information it's it's a great read and
if you read you'll probably kind of
it'll resonate with you in different
places that you've worked and so that
and that really made me think about how
little I understood about true teamwork
and
how many of the people around me didn't
really understand it either so I guess
the way I would leave it is you know
when we talk about good culture it's a
very amorphous concept what's good for
me maybe different for Andrew maybe
difference based on different
organizations different requirements and
so forth but what is what is I always
find interesting is when particularly
when you're interviewing people people
can't always describe what the perfect
culture is but they can very clearly
tell you what bad cultures they've been
part of so you know what are the
behaviors it could be that one
experience of the 201st experience they
had with an executive that was
completely out of character with you
know what a company says but you know
it's it's a matter of feeling what's
right for you at that moment in time
what's right for the employees who are
there but there's so much of good
culture it's just common sense it's just
things that they're just certain things
you don't do you treat people who
respectfully you have to you know you
have to give people you have to empower
them you can allow them to make
decisions as long as there's a core
baseline of values that you subscribe to
everything else you put on top is okay
it's just the bad stuff is universal
okay so I think a lot has already been
said I would say that for some of you
that are considering entrepreneurship
especially a lot of you have worked for
what there's private equity banking
consulting you haven't really had to
think about this developing of the
culture one thing to think about as a
founder an entrepreneur is your
visibility is extraordinarily powerful
and more so than you can even imagine
there is you know a magnifying glass on
everything you do everything you say
do them good and bad and leave a lot of
people talked about feedback feedbacks
extremely important you gotta be careful
about doing it in public anything that
you say some small constructive feedback
is magnified ten times by the person
that's receiving it just because of your
role as a founder and a company that's a
hard thing to adjust to you're out of
business school wow these people are
hanging on my every word I come in the
office and I look stressed out that
stresses other people out I come in
and I'm happy that makes other people
happy it's very a very surreal
experience too when you start to realize
how visible you are and how much people
are looking at your every action and
every action that you take is is
creating that culture I totally agree
with that I mean in it you it's a
constant evolution in learning because
that visibility in that sort of how
people hang on what you say is is
changing all the time and it's different
and different people react to things
differently I I would totally do with
that I think the thing that I would say
to take away that probably people won't
tell you about culture is that it's it's
very very dynamic right and there are
core values that Scott talks about that
are just sort of fundamental things of
you got to decide what what you want to
do and those things will be part of the
character forever but in terms of the
systems and the incentives and rewards
on its that we mean it changes a lot and
you know I think you got to be prepared
for that iteration cycle especially in
entrepreneurial and it's okay it's okay
and I would say always remember that
take a little bit of a longer term view
then then feels necessarily comfortable
please join me in thanking our panel